thanks to all the submissions from you
today i'll be covering the top 10 spells
you want to see
in hogwarts legacy people of the
internet retro rack and tour here
if we're meeting for the first time i'm
just a dad who loves games and the
stories they tell
we post videos every week here on
youtube and also stream over on twitch
and today's video is all about you
that's right your
ideas and suggestions for spells that
you want to see in hogwarts legacy
in a recent video i gave you five spells
i'd love to see in hogwarts legacy
and then asked you to submit your ideas
and boy did you guys
respond i mean look at this right here
[Music]
first off i want to say thank you to
everyone who commented with their ideas
for spells
this video wouldn't have been possible
without your suggestions
the five spells i suggested were episky
mafliato
the patronus charm ridiculous and
protego
thanks to one eagle-eyed commenter for
pointing out two things regarding these
spells
one severus snape is actually the wizard
who invented muffliato
and he did while he was at hogwarts this
means the spell wasn't created until
around
1971 at the earliest which means
sadly there's no chance we'll see it in
hogwarts legacy without breaking the
canon of course
speaking of spells invented by snape
sektum simpra was a spell that came up a
few times in the comments
however like muffliato it was also
invented by snape
same for levicorpus too in case you're
wondering on the positive side though
this same commenter also pointed out
that another one of my ideas protego
is most likely confirmed to be in the
game thanks to the official trailer
it's easy to miss but if you watch this
moment here just before the troll
strikes
you can see the wizard executing a
shield-like spell that seems to deflect
the attack
back from the troll so good news protego
is likely
in but enough about my list let's get to
the spells you guys most want to see
in hogwarts legacy number one flippandoo
i'm sorry i just can't not say it like
that i love that you guys suggested this
one because
it's all about the nostalgia here
flopindo of course is the knockbacks
jinx and it was used
rather frequently in the original harry
potter and the sorcerer's stone video
game
there are various times throughout the
book series this spell was probably used
but as far as
i can remember the incantation has only
appeared in the video games
honestly i hope this one isn't overused
because let's be honest here it was
probably way overused in the games
[Music]
for nostalgia purposes though it would
be great to see it make an appearance
even if it's almost like an easter egg
number two
the unforgivable curses okay you
actually get three spells in one right
here avada cadaver crucio
and imperio and man you guys have
absolutely not hidden the fact that you
can't wait to wield some dark magic and
stay away from you guys
in another of my recent hogwarts legacy
videos i asked whether you would want to
play as good or
evil and so many of you have responded
evil so it's no surprise to see the
unforgivables make an appearance
here let's go through them one by one
avada kadavra also known as the killing
curse that took the lives of harry's
parents
could work but this would likely need to
be a late game spell in order to keep it
from being
overused or overpowering perhaps there
could be some sort of anger or rage
meter that needs to be powered before
you could use it
in the books the killing curse can't be
used unless the caster
truly means it they need the anger and
rage to actually see another person
vanquished in order for it to work as
for crucio
i mean yikes it's a curse purely
intended to torture the person on the
receiving end of it
like a vodacadabra you also have to
truly mean it
i'm not sure if they could work this one
into the game and still maintain
the t rating that i'm sure they're
striving toward imperial on the other
hand has a lot of interesting
implications for how it could be used in
the game
you see it's a spell that allows the
caster to take over the mind of another
person and
control them basically and as i'm sure
you guys can as well i can think of
quite a few gaming scenarios where this
one could be very useful for solving
puzzles or making your way through
certain stealth levels
what's interesting is that unlike avada
kadavra and crucio this one
isn't about anger hate or inflicting
pain on another person
in fact can you remember when harry
actually used this one in the books
if so let me know down in the comments
number three
a pugno i really like the suggestion
here for the exact
reason the commenter mentioned which is
the animation
possibilities see a pugno is actually a
jinx that directs
other objects to attack just ask ron
about the flocks of birds that hermione
sent his way
this spell could be used on conjured
magical creatures
bits of parchment as you're running
through the castle or maybe a pile of
leaves as you're exploring the forbidden
forest
number four petrificus totalis we all
remember this iconic scene from movie
one when neville found himself
on the other end of this spell thanks to
hermione
also known as the full body bind it's
essentially a
freezing spell that temporarily
paralyzes an opponent
locking their limbs to their side this
is a spell that would obviously be
very useful within the context of the
hogwarts legacy video game and i would
be
pretty shocked if we don't see it number
five legitimates
okay now we're officially in the
territory of some really intense
gameplay moments if spells like
legitimates are in the picture
this charm gives the caster access to
the mind of another wizard
it's not the same as imperial which
takes control
over another's mind legitimates on the
other hand allows the caster to
explore one's memories a cluemancy is
the defense against the spell and it's
what snape attempts to teach harry in
harry potter and the order of the
phoenix we already know that our
character in hogwarts legacy is said to
have a
rare ability perhaps their skilled
legitimates
number 6 glacius on the opposite side of
incendio we have
glacious the freezing spell this charm
can
freeze opposing targets as well as water
can also be used for extinguishing fires
along with aguamenti of course
as well as cooling off fire dwelling
salamanders
i love how the commenter who suggested
this mentioned using it in
creative ways such as maybe freezing the
ground nearby to make creatures or
attacking wizards slip and fall
number 7 confringeo confrencho is known
as a
blasting curse that can cause targets to
explode
that's right explode according to the
harry potter wiki which is a fantastic
resource by the way
peter pettigrew aka wormtail used this
spell in the mass killing of 12 muggles
in 1981.
that being said it's not always lethal
and could be used in
dueling as well number eight
expelliarmus
speaking of dueling there's no way this
one isn't in right i mean expelliarmus
may be the most
iconic spell of the entire series harry
uses it so much that lupin even tells
him that the death eaters have come to
recognize it as his signature move
that being said though it did work out
for him in both of his face-to-face
meetings with
voldemort so who's to judge of course in
normal use expelliarmus is a spell for
disarming your opponent
when used correctly it should result in
the other wizard losing their wand
number nine
protego diabolica my list featured
protego but you guys want to see protego
diabolica this is a dark charm that
creates a ring of protection made of
black fire
around its caster the spell is unique in
that allies of the caster can pass
through the flames unharmed
enemies on the other hand will be burned
if it sounds familiar to you then it's
because you probably remember it from
the climax of fantastic beasts the
crimes of grindelwald
number 10 fiend fire this is by far
one of the most powerful and damaging
spells on our list
when crabb uses the spell in the final
chapters of harry potter and the deathly
hallows
harry doesn't even recognize the spell
it produces
massive flames that grow rapidly in both
size
and heat the fire itself can take the
form of enormous serpents dragons or
other beasts that pursue live targets in
fact fiendfire is so
powerful that it's one of the few
methods of destroying a horcrux
we have plenty of other hogwarts legacy
videos for you to check out just click
the playlist here on the right side of
the screen
thank you all so much for your
suggestions for watching
and i'll talk to you again soon